this episode brought to you by audible
the most inspiring minds the most
compelling stories the best place to
listen previously on exports Jon Snow
Lord Commander Mormont has requested you
this cost when you have children always
at them the bullshit is family is on
trial for his life turn it on an island
no one's coming for us
I have to tape you've been looking for
really um me I want you to work for me
[Applause]
what's next
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome back to X month
get the idea oh the first x-men movie
being a surprise hit Fox wasted no time
getting a sequel in the works and giving
it a much bigger budget this resulted in
x2 x-men United these stupidest a movie
in the franchise yeah men was too hard
for the kids to say so we'll just put it
under the title and make it look like a
really cool math problem regardless
x-men 2 x-men United because the X
stands for x-men you're using the title
twice that stuff is a big hit with
critics and audiences it was a smash at
the box office in four years people
would say this was the best x-men movie
because of N equals wow that okay equals
a once again I have to ask is it worthy
of the praise with how far comic book
movies have come did this add to moving
them forward or slow down progress at a
time when we just couldn't see it well
let's prepare by once again fetishizing
the color blue seriously yes or no other
color let's take a look at x2 x-men
United I mean we could call it t 2
terminators back the TRA stands for
terminator it doesn't add all the film
opens once again with Patrick Stewart
talking about mutation as well as this
little sneak peek at future botched
story lines we got to the White House
where a suspicious figure appears to
have appeared excuse me sir
are you lost mr. Assad you know you're
not allowed back here again
this is a mutant named Nightcrawler
played by Alan Cumming giving us let's
be honest the best part he seemingly
tries to kill the president but he
stopped at the last minute and after
that fast-paced scene with awesome
effects and a great makeup job let's cut
to a slow as shit scene with bad green
screaming and poorly clued on the
sideburns this is Wolverine played once
again by Hugh Jackman exploring an
abandoned lab at a dam where he was
given his and a mantium skeleton and
attacked a bag of exploding flour on the
way out meanwhile at a museum we see
Xavier students on a field trip led by
Cyclops played again by James Marsden
Benji played again by famke janssen and
I do hope you enjoy clips of her looking
lost and confused cuz that's all the
character development you're gonna get
out of her in this flick a shame she has
so much of an identity in the last film
such as Wolverine liked her she seems
unable to control her powers and feels
impending doom on the horizon keep
feeling something terrible's about hey
psychic joy can predict the future
something's happening in the food court
meanwhile rope played again by Anna
Paquin hangs with Bobby pyro and Jack
Black's thrust face hey yeah I get used
to these obnoxiously warts Bryan Singer
close-ups this is kind of when he
decided that's his style now he uses it
so much everybody looks like that creepy
Humpty Dumpty from that kinder
commercial uses his powers and
appropriately when I don't know
somewhere second or it's just a timeout
I did actually this is the work of
Xavier played again by Patrick Stewart
who mentally freezes everybody which is
a power that several times in these
movies would have saved the day but when
he says hypocritical stuff like next
time you feel like showing off while
showing off just wiping a few memories
would have been fine you can't be
surprised they don't really do logical
things in this movie like hire a
gardener somehow I thought you were here
to talk about school reform
meanwhile at the White House Brian Cox
talks with the president and Senator
Kelly who is still mystique in disguise
Senator Kelly this is Colonel William
Stryker Stryker
he brings up that Xavier school as a
training ground for mutants that could
possibly be planning an attack where
would they get an idea like that hell is
that a jet that comes up out of the
basketball court you'll notice the
outlines of several flattened children
around it you enter you detain you
question but the last thing we need to
see is the body of a mutant kid on the
six o'clock news again their basketball
court seems perfectly capable of that
mr. striker do you really want to turn
this into some kind of war
I was piloted in black ops missions in
the jungles of North Vietnam well you
were sucking on your mama's tit at
Woodstock Ellie you are literally both
the exact same age but you show that
youngster hippie meanwhile Wolverine
returns but Bobby isn't so happy to see
him because rogue is so happy to see him
this is Bobby call me Iceman
okay I'm maverick which one of us is
goose he tells Xavier he didn't find
shit at the lab but Xavier doesn't care
because he just found someone to watch
the kids while they completely abandon
them again you will be kind enough to
watch over the children tonight once
again the four people who look after
this gigantic place will be out we can
afford the military plane but
babysitter's mmm Jean accompanied by
storm play to get by Halle Berry thank
God accent West this time has brown hair
track down the German base Nightcrawler
in where else Boston yes house
now those abandoned churches in Boston
with people that speak English but speak
German because it shows their German
they force him to come down as he
reveals that he had little control over
his attack I could see it all happening
it was like a bad dream he talks like
this every time someone brings up some
of the masks
I mean well Xavier and Cyclops visit
Magneto
played again by Ian McKellen all right
Scott oh if only he can read his mind to
know that this was a trap yeah nobody's
powers make sense in these I fought it
face my broccoli and bean burrito of
nostril eater
ah I'll get you next time we'll meet
again you and I are not so different I
got a million of these the leader of the
x-men everybody reflexes like a cat if
it was Garfield dead by the way it'll be
almost an hour before you see him again
in the movie I know it's been fancied
cyclists but when x-men itself hates
Cyclops I think there's a problem
somewhere so it turns out this giant
school slash a military base lash one
man guarded establishment doesn't have a
security system you want these children
to die as soldiers break in
tranquilizing them forcing Wolverine and
others to fight back yeah well number
one Xavier said at the end of the last
movie when asked what he'll do if
somebody tries to break in I feel a
great swell of pity for the poor so who
comes to that school looking for trouble
glad to see he was totally prepared for
that no alarm system no security leaving
the school completely abandoned except
for one person looking after him Xavier
school for the gifted where children
come first and go first non Russian
Colossus finds a secret way out yeah
there's secret passages but no alarm
Facebook has better security than you as
rogue decides to separate from the group
because she's rogue what would she know
about fighting back
who could it be it's nice to finally see
Wolverines digging into bad guys and
stuff chopping walls and fences and
middle finger but all of that stops when
he recognizes a familiar voice I didn't
realize Xavier was taken in animals even
animals as unique as you every line he
has sounds like the narration from big
fish
I didn't realize Xavier was taken in
animals all the same I preferred to keep
my bones unbroken Bobby puts a nice ring
between them and Wolverine leads them to
the garage where he starts a car with
his claw cuz that's totally something he
can do now Oh
flaming shit does that work exactly I
don't like uncomfortable songs
let it be known that x-men hates NSYNC
meanwhile in a bar we see a cameo
that'll age grade as mystique played
again by Rebecca romaine tries to flirt
with one of Magneto's guards now it's a
singer film she injects him with iron
while we see Stryker Holt Xavier captive
while controlling other mutants with a
brain altering drunk naturally this is
injected into the brain by dropping a
small amount of liquid behind the neck
yeah that's sure it turns out strikers
child is a powerful psychopath that he
tortured until he gained back control so
this is all secretly a sequel for Brian
Cox's ring character my son is dead just
like the rest of you
so um how about this place not having a
ramp it's kind of bullshit is it okay
small talk over Bobby invites everyone
to his parents house where they try to
gain their senses and figure out what to
do next
these are my grandmother's I dug her up
myself Thanks
it looks like the GAR mystique injected
carries the iron in his blood for
magneto to use as a weapon I really
don't think that's how iron in the
bloodstream worse but who cares at least
to a pretty badass Code Red
marbles we have marbles this on the
other hand looks a little silly
I just don't seem right ago Roomba has
especially threatening
I just won't play this sound effect over
it if Marvin the Martian fluid this
would be the greatest Marvel crossover
ever meanwhile Bobby's parents come home
and discover for the first time that
he's a mutant have you tried not being a
mutant there's a cable news channel I'm
pretty sure says you can do that
speaking of which ice man's brother
named Arnold I need a nice pun frosty
thank you calls the police on them all
right the rest of you on the ground now
I think you'll be fine
pyro attacks them as Gina's storm remind
everybody they're in this movie as
Wolverine gets up you mean he didn't die
what a nice man leaves his family um sad
I guess I mean we didn't get to know
them well for their two minutes on
screen another brother tried to have him
killed
even the mothers expression is out of
focus and matter so widdle and she had
the most lines but um this is what it's
all about zero you can move her a little
to the left about it's all right you can
come on oh yeah I forgot about this so
strike your son controls Xavier mind to
make him control their version of
cerebro to kill all the mutants in the
world yeah that took what five seconds
to explain but the movie constantly cuts
back to this slow-moving scene where the
Sun is convincing him he's a lost girl
Xavier is back at the mansion and he has
to take her to cerebro and it drags on
and on and on every time it cuts back to
them it brings everything to a
screeching monotonous halt and the funny
thing is the illusions not even needed
as soon as he's in there the girl
instructs him to kill all the mutants
which he attempts to do
good well clearly he would never do that
showing the Sun has complete control
over his mind so why even make all this
up did you just want to give a tour of
the damn place until your right is a
wall and to your left is a wall and to
your right is a wall and to your left is
a naked pig don't worry though that's
followed by a boring ass plane chase as
the military sees them as a threat and
tries to shoot them down through storms
tornadoes okay so it's nice to see some
bigger effects in these movies even
though they do look a little fake but
again it's x-men mutants monsters aliens
why are we focusing on a military base
they just randomly pass by they didn't
kidnap Xavier they have no involvement
in all this so who cares hey remember
that one issue where they battled the
greatest enemy air traffic control
probably not because nobody would want
to read it so not me won't want to watch
it broke it sucked out though because
one of their seat belts are broken I
swear to god they want every student
dead crawler save Serah as they as well
get saved by an unlikely comrade when
will these people learn how to fly
ah so even he hates what they did to
rogue
[Applause]
[Music]
one of my favorite books ever is George
Orwell's Animal Farm but I'll admit it's
hard to read when you work it all the
time
[Music]
oh wow that's why it makes more sense to
use audible with audible you can access
to an unbeatable selection of audio
books including bestsellers motivation
mysteries thrillers memoirs and bar you
can multitask by listening to them and
stuff having to carry your book around
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet and now with
audible originals the selection has
gotten even more custom with content
made for members one of my favorite
books ever is Animal Farm by George
Orwell but you already know that
inaudible has it that's cool honorable
members can choose three titles every
month one audiobook and two audible
originals you can't hear anywhere else
although both members also get access to
exclusive audio fitness programs to
start the new year off on the right foot
[Music]
listen on a device anytime anywhere at
home at the gym on your commute or just
on the go you'll also be able to enjoy
easy audio book exchange rollover
credits and an audio book library you
keep forever even if you cancel get
started with a 30-day trial when you go
to audible.com slash nostalgic or text
nostalgic to 500 500 and listen for a
change
that's audible.com slash nostalgic AUD
ible dot-com slash nostalgic to start
your 30-day trial I don't want to give
the wrong impression actually it's a
really good book you should you should
check it out go to audible it's it's
it's good get audible and check this
book out too classic
I don't know what I'm doing the most
inspiring minds the most compelling
stories the best place to listen
you
[Music]
hey everybody just letting you know
we're gonna be at c2e2 in Chicago
that's me Brad Jones Rob Malcolm Tamra
and a whole bunch of the channel awesome
gang are gonna be there we also have a
panel movies everybody disagrees with
you on where you get to talk about the
movie that everybody
well disagrees with you on it's your
panel it's a lot of fun we've got the
booth at this khand a ton of times it's
a lot of fun and we'll see you there
[Music]
[Applause]
so let me always awesome alliance of
convenience trope magneto teams up with
the x-men to stop Stryker after he
reveals he's going to use Xavier to
destroy all the mutants of the world we
don't know where this base is one of you
my professor already tried once again
you think it's all about you have you
seen the posters for this franchise it
is all about him they read nightcrawlers
mind and discover the lab is where
wolverine went but it was hidden
underground funny how his heightened
sense of smell didn't pick up the dozens
of people that were literally under his
nose oh yeah I forget this was the thing
it's pretty bad in the maximum movie
when you forget Logan wants Jean but
we've had whole seconds of chemistry had
seconds but if you think that romance
isn't well built up mystique now out of
nowhere suddenly has a thing for Logan
this has never been brought up before
and will never be brought up after it's
the Julia Roberts getting big and Hudson
apparently the only reason this scene
was in the movie was to get image of its
two biggest stars Hugh Jackman and Halle
Berry in bed together this is ironic
because there's tons of comic material
with Wolverine and storm as a couple but
somehow it was easier to have missed a
spontaneous ly horny for him how is a
Hugh Jackman had no problem with his
character having several beautiful women
on top of him I just realized I answered
my own question
speaking of spontaneous T must make you
know an pyro talked for a minute and
that immediately justifies him turning
evil by the end
in a magnifying glass to an ant sort of
way I'm sorry I can't follow this map
unless you use needles can you teleport
inside no I have to be able to see where
I'm going or in a plane spinning midair
out of control they're both basically
the same thing magneto doesn't want to
take a chance on Wolverine because he
doesn't know the technology to open the
doors so he looks towards mystique which
is why none of us are surprised when
it's revealed that this is mystique but
honestly I'll give it a pass because it
gave us this gift
how many fans use that on future x-men
movies she's good that's what you meant
by you have blue balls the x-men
searched the place to try and find the
kids when Wolverine decides it's car the
kids I just want to know where I came
from if they're like a list of worst
movie schools ever he was the babysitter
by the way a cyclops Dillon x-men oh
there is you know for x-men United they
sure are separated dividing or fighting
against each other a lot aren't they it
looks like he's been brainwashed too as
he attacks Jean but she diverts the hit
to the dam so just a reminder all the
misery that is to follow it's completely
his fault I do so many kid shows having
likeable leaders it's okay but luckily
Jean snaps him out of it with I honestly
don't know a big boom I guess as looking
finds the room where Stryker
experimented on him discovering that he
was experimented on and Stryker did it
so now the goddam tagging oh wait we do
find out that anime Neum has to be hot
that should tide us over until our
inevitable disappointment Stryker six
his bodyguard named death strike on him
now in the comic they had this huge
rivalry you already know they don't care
as is par with these movies Wolverine
always gets the funniest where shit at
some point they'll put together that the
more they haven't swear the better the
movie will get we get a pretty decent
fight between them and even a pretty
cool death scene but it looks like
Walmart cerebro has located all the
mutants for Xavier and his brainwashed
mind tries to kill them all but magneto
stops him plays wall Tetris and in my
always favorite scene when bad guys team
up with good guys the bad guys
inevitably turn into dickheads again
striker tries to escape but Wolverine
stops him before he takes off if you
really know about your past the work we
did together what we did to blob gambit
and Deadpool it's too awful to conceive
he made sure Stryker doesn't leave as
the x-men saves the kids but have to get
inside to stop Xavier from killing
mankind I need you to take me if I can't
see that I'm going I have faith I mean
you totally caught a person midair
without seeing where she was
there was no window facing her and yet
you got her on the first try looks like
you were facing away from the plane when
you teleported back so I really don't
see how this is a big deal oh he made it
thank God so suspenseful it looks like
storm needs to free strike her son in
order to break the illusion it's about
to get very cold why can't he just warp
out and then walk back in which he's
done and why can't she just keep
Nightcrawler warm the same way she's
clearly keeping herself work maybe she
saw Viva rock Vegas I'm glad to punish
him it seems to work as they saved the
professor we get the closest thing we'll
ever see two rogue flying and Magneto
again runs into Stryker who has plans
for him he moves him over there kind of
the equivalent of duct-taping someone to
a wall doesn't seem that bad pyro ends
up joining Magneto it was a very
convincing two-minute talk but the dam
is about to break apart resulting in
let's just be honest the most
nonsensical of escape plans here we go
gene walks out of the plane lifts the
plane in the air pulls a Moses and then
sacrifices herself to the water really
that was the only way Iceman Cometh
frozen the water this was the only way
storm couldn't have stopped the water
this is the only way Xavier couldn't
have lifted the plane from inside she
couldn't have lifted the plane from
inside you just really wanted a wrath of
Kondos because you're such a Star Trek
bitch that you even took a small part
pushing buttons and one of the most
hated of Star Trek movies didn't you
this is an edited version of Bryan
Singer saying yes I know
listen to me
we barely had something together she
lets the water finally engulf her as the
x-men put together that Gina's dead
she's gone home is how we knew nothing
about our outside of how poorly she
teased the next movie the president is
about to make an address about harsher
laws on mutants when Xavier freezes the
production to let him know that not all
mutants are threatening while
threatening the everliving shit out of
him then you also know I don't respond
well to threats mr. president this is
not a threat this is an opportunity fine
lightning is totally to put your mind at
ease there are forces in this world who
believe that a war is coming
some have already tried to start one and
there have been casualties casualties we
barely knew Oh totally not a threat we
are so watching so America completely
ignores that four minutes of dead air
and the president decides not to push
for harsher laws on mutants well first
of all I really doubt that would fly but
let's with the sake of argument say that
is what happened in America the entire
world was attacked
even if the US backed down every other
country will be World War 3 the hell out
of this yet but for the sake of I don't
know just ending this almost two and a
half hour movie the plan works and
Wolverine lets Cyclops know Jean loved
him most she didn't make a choice who is
you wait a minute did you have a thing
for you over oh oh yeah you didn't know
about that dumb welcome in Iraq what
he's not even a character yet depth and
in case you had any doubt this movie was
a total Star Trek to rip off here's the
opening narration read by the person who
just died building up that they're gonna
be back in the next film with almost the
exact same music space the final
frontier
mutation it is the key to our evolution
where no man has gone before but every
few hundred millennia evolution leaps
forward
[Music]
oh my god the Firebird you crushed those
expectations right now
so that was x2 what's hailed by many to
be one of the best if not the best x-men
movie how impressive is that again
honestly the film is super long
needlessly slow has a ton of pointless
moments even more plot holes than the
first one and way too many characters to
give them enough time to be interesting
what that said though there is an
occasional moment of coolness a nice
action sequence here and there and
mostly a fair amount of good acting to
make me care just enough it's definitely
on the lower level of okay but it is
still okay nothing special but nothing
that bad either it's a mostly boring
mostly inconsistent but mostly harmless
comic-book adaptation then hey seeing
how much this film is building up the
next one it has to pay off right on the
Joker no big
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here not only doing the
charity shout out but also showing you a
short film it is called pip it is about
a guide dog and it ties into the charity
V South Eastern guide dogs this is a
wonderful charity its address is guide
dogs with an S org different from
another one idea which was guide dog org
both of them are wonderful charities but
this short film is really friggin
adorable it's really sweet it's got tons
and tons of hits and you can see why
it's super super cute you're gonna want
to donate to this wonderful cause after
seeing the short film so the link I'm
putting in there is the one that links
to the short film that also has a donate
button on there so you can check that
out but if you want go to the original
site you can go to guide dogs with an S
Dorcas guide dog will also take you to a
great charity but what we're focusing on
this one today so uh go check out the
short film donate it just give it as
much attention as possible because these
are people that do really great things
and they put together a really great
short so that's about it go check it out
and enjoy take care
you